When making dinner tonight,
I realized we were all out of our condiments,
so I decided to do a little restock.
Today we're making some ketchup,
ranch, barbecue sauce, and hot sauce.
So I started with my ketchup,
combining tomato paste,
some honey, vinegar, and water,
simmering that on the stove
before pulling that off and letting it cool,
and I moved on to making some ranch.
I like a lot of herbs in it,
but you can tone that down if you want.
So I chopped up some parsley,
dill, chives and combined that in a bowl with some mayonnaise,
sour cream, some whole milk,
and gave that a good mix
before adding in some lemon juice and cracked black pepper and salt.
I adjusted the seasoning based on what I wanted
before putting it in the fridge to chill.
For my hot sauce,
I chopped up some Fresno chilies,
added some garlic,
black pepper, corn, and vinegar, and diluted that with some water.
Then I simmered that for 20 minutes on the stove
while I made my barbecue sauce.
I combined the ketchup we made earlier with some brown sugar,
vinegar, and some other seasoning, and letting that thicken on the stove,
and once it hit the thickness I wanted,
I transferred that over to a bowl to cool.
I blended up my peppers and strained them.
I was pretty happy with my hot sauce consistency
since I wanted it more runny.
That's how I prep some of My favorite condiments